thank
you good evening and welcome to this
meeting extraordinary meeting of molden
District Council held on Wednesday the
29th of November
2023 my name is councelor Kevin lagen
and I'm the chairperson of the council
members and all present we are streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting
you're giving your consent to being
recorded during each item please put
your hand up to indicate if you wish to
speak I will then invite you at the
appropriate time could I ask members to
avoid approaching the top table as it
could create interference with the
cameras and the live stream and please
note that the YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on correct use of
microphones therefore can I ask that
when invited to speak you remember to
turn your microphone on and turn it off
when finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible please item two is apologies
for absence Tara may we have apologies
for absence please yes thank you
apologies we Reed from
coun andoun morning thank you thank you
very much indeed T we move on to agenda
item three which is the minutes of the
14th of September 2020 three which are
paid on 5
to4 um members uh can I take the minutes
as as r c fluka
please d
sorry chair I've dropped out civa so you
just have to let me if you don't mind J
I'll just lock back in
okay good
evening
thank you chairman I'm I'm grateful for
that um you're welcome chairman minute
246 as a point of accuracy um chairman
dur whilst the that uh agenda isem is
being debated the number of PR number of
people present at those meetings was
challenged because later on you'll see
this is a argument that's been put
forward for off one of the arguments
being put forward by officers and it was
challenged in relation to video evidence
and I checked it again tonight chairman
and and I do wish those numbers had been
included because I think it puts a
different dimension and also chairman
there was a mention during that meeting
and it's this equally as important that
it should have been recorded uh and that
was um the upload and download speeds
and the Ping
latency um which is very very important
when it when it comes to this item and
it is important CH for I think because
it's being debated later we should not
be put into that what point of the
meeting the minutes are you pointing to
for accuracy please uh chairman it was
under I've already referred to that um
so chairman and again that is important
because it has to be taken in the
context of what we're going to discuss
later so chairman I I I would ask those
two those two points are recorded and
that members note what I've said thank
you but I will bring it up of course at
the next did you not that
Tara thank you members can we agree the
rest of the minutes minutes by asent
please thank you members uh move on to
item four which is Declarations of
interest is to decloseting and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and
non-registered interests relating to
items of business on the agenda have in
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
are reminded that they are also required
to disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting member do we have
any declarations please
please Tara there's no hands going up so
no declarations thank you thank you move
to item five which is public questions
uh we have one public questions from
councelor Mr Tom Kelly Mr Kelly if you'd
like to come forward to the
table if we can find a microphone for Mr
Kelly I've got two questions Mr chairman
and I come with a health
hazard or health warning
hazard why doesn't MDC encourage anglian
water especially in the overall current
sewage
crisis to provide a much higher level of
antibacterial protection in molden
rivers than current
levels irrespective of the minimum
levels set by the department of the
environment at government
level thus giving River
users an especially
molden mud River users and the mud race
users competitors Better Health and
well-being
standards you okay would you like me to
do the second one uh I think we do both
together yes please Mr
Kelly why hasn't there been an
increase in the permanent Staffing level
at ground level for areas such as the
three
cemeteries but there is a large number a
bit like NHS Bureau bureaucracy of
managers and
directors at what cost and the Reliance
on
contractors or
volunteers the latter subject to the
dictates of a health and safety officer
despite their years of
experience isn't it time members had a
proper look on site to understand
things thank you thank you Mr Kelly I
refer to the leader to respond to the
questions thank you uh thank you
chair uh in response to question one
unfortunately the council has no
regulatory jurisdiction over anglian
water and any storm water discharges
from their system into our rivers and
ditch networks the envirment agency is a
regulatory body and through a permitting
permitting system regulate Wastewater
discharge activities they are also
responsible for taking appropriate
enforcement action when environmental
crimes are identified including the
unregulated discharge of foul water
modern District Council is not able to
dictate water quality levels however our
officers do work in partnership with the
east east anglian water at the
environment agency and will in share
intelligence to assist whether
investigations where pollution incidents
are
identified as part of this approach the
council also coordinates group meetings
where representatives from anglian water
attend items for discussion including
Improvement plans for the seage network
in and around the District of molden are
included it is through these groups that
we can get the opportunity to understand
what improvements to the Su systems are
planned and ask the questions about how
these will be prior I for our district
and the council will ensure that
councelor Kelly's concerns are taken to
those
groups thank you very much indeed leader
we move on to item I've got a do
question too oh sorry I done that that
was gracian head my apologies
leader the council recognizes the
importance of ensuring that we provide
peaceful well-maintained cemeteries
where our residents can mourn their
loved ones and our staff strive to
deliver a good level of service service
across all of our three
cemeteries we are currently exploring
opportunities to ensure that we are able
to provide greater resilience to the
maintenance of our cemeteries this
includes the way in which we Service as
delivered as well as opportunities to
improve the layout of some areas to
enable us to manage the maintenance to
maximum Effectiveness I have Mr
councelor Kelly's concerns on this and
during the summer my mailbag was full
and I have seen lots of pictures about
what the cognition was at that
particular time we are looking at how we
can improve the way in which we work uh
and support our volunteers who add value
to the maintenance of our cemeteries a
report was considered by strategy and
resources committee this month and
proposals were agreed to deliver greater
resilience and maintain a more
consistent standard of Grounds
Maintenance across our cemeteries we
have to ensure that our cemeteries are a
credit to the district and to those that
rest there and it's something that I
will ensure that we continue looking at
and continue and to improve the standard
of the service that we've been
providing thank you leer great
appreciate it keep thank you thank you
uh Chairman's announcements I I just
have a couple members um again as per
normal I'm suspending rule four part
eight section three the need to stand
unless you wish um also want to say that
um we had a quiz Chairman's quiz
recently which raised £
36410 for the David Randall Foundation
which I was very very pleased with and
also to continue sending our our best
regards to uh Bob boy SBE on his
continued
recovery you we move on to agenda item
seven which is the mini book so to
consider the recommendations coming from
from the Committees detailed below
please note that the minutes of these
meetings are not inclosed there has not
been approved at committee level and
it's strategy and resources Committee of
the 21st of September 2023 found on
pages 15 to8 it's agenda item 272 feed
and charges policy 2024-25 uh Miss Lucas
is going to present and clarify the
report thank
you thank you chair um yeah the report
is as set out um um and proposed to be
um recommended to council by strategy
and resources um at their September
meeting however um it's just subject to
one Amendment um which is to reflect the
decision previously made by Council in
February of this year which was to apply
the 50% discount on Warf fees for the um
three-year period up until the end of
the financial year 2025
26 um it should be noted that the um the
policy that's um being asked to be
approved um is just the policy document
and the um detailed fees and charges
schedule um that was considered by a
later strategy and resources committee
um in November will be brought back to
Council on the 14th of December um but
yeah apart from that one Amendment we're
asking that um that that policy fees and
charges policy for the next financial
year is approved thank you thank you Mr
Lucas so the recommendation is that
20242 fees and charges policy at
appendix a be approved do I have a
seconder council fluka first Sorry
seconded by counc Thompson you chairman
I'm I'm it always concerns me that we
agreed the policy which we have to to do
of course and then we agree how the fees
and charges change but of course in this
particular instance we seem to be
slightly out of kilter because we were
actually looking at fees and charges at
the last meeting of strategy and
resources and and chairman I I I just to
highlight this issue I just ask members
or Draw their attention to page 16 and
and the second item down chairman um it
it's marked up in red uh and and
chairman and for those that haven't
found it uh it says proposed proposed
policy for
2425 uh minimum of full cost recovery
and in line in line in line with other
authorities now chairman a proposal is
being tabled at strategy and resources
to increase the green Bing fee by I I
can't remember what it is but it's
certainly over 101 P per anom um I be on
might be 20 somewhere between 10 and 20
which generally I I I I I see as a on
recycling which is not something that I
think we should be doing counc fluka
just just for clarity
we we talking you're not you're talking
detail it's been very clearly lied out
it's talked out thank you counc fluka um
we're talking about recommending not the
individual items that are on there when
it comes to Council in November that's
the time when we will go through them
chairman what I'm what I'm saying to
members is we are discussing policy and
the policy on here is what I'm
questioning I'm not questioning the
charge I'm really mentioning the
proposed increasing charge to give good
Prejudice to the fact that we are
talking here at full cost recovery
chairman and I think you'd be delighted
to know that that service generates a
surplus of over £350,000 a year already
and that chairman I would propose that
we remove the words and in line with
other authorities because some
authorities do charge more than us
because they're not so good at providing
the service from a fiscal point of view
but chairman otherwise you will be
seeing the green beans going up uh and
chairman I've just realized and and I'd
hate Mr quch to choke on his drink but I
I should maybe have asked for a
dispensation because I Mrs fluka has a
green bin um but chairman this
highlights when we accept a policy
through this document how that can
impact when we look at the charge so
chairman I have made a proposal and I'd
ask you to put it to counsel thank you
you have made a proposal um is that
proposal
seconded okay so what we have we
actually have one recommendation which
was seconded by Council to councelor
Thompson did you did you second that
proposal you did Council Thompson I
believe y so what we need to do is we
need to vote on the F first proposal and
then if that fails go on to the second
councelor daram you wanted to speak um I
might point out in in relation to the
comment um in line with other
authorities some authorities don't
charge with their green we to all thank
you okay members so we'll go for the
substantive motion first of all the
first recommendation is that the 2024
2025 fees and charges policy at appendix
one be approved um going have a show of
hands
four so that's one two three four five
six
seven 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
164 so that's carried okay so thank you
your points have been noted Council
fluka thank you um oh yeah this not this
is not time for politics thank you um
number eight minutes of the meetings of
the council please uh to note that since
the last Council up until Tuesday the
21st of November 2023 Council agenda
dispatch the following committees have
met and to receive any questions in
accordance with Council committee
procedure 6 little two and those uh
minutes that are closed are District
planning on the 6th of September
Northwest area planning committee on the
13th of September Southeastern area
planning committee on the 20th of
September strategy and resources
committee on the 21st of September
performance governance and audit
committee on the 28th of September
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
as the crime and disorder committee on
the 12th of October Northwest area
planning committee on the 8th of
November strategy and resources
committee on the 9th of November
Southeast area planning committee on the
15th of November and performance
governance and audit committee uh
meeting on the 16th of November uh the
propos that these are noted and agreed
by asent any agreed thank you
members we move on to notice of a motion
uh to consider the following motion
that's been received by councelor
fluka uh on the 14th uh motion number 14
2023 in accordance with notice duly
given under procedure rule four
councelor as Fluker to move the
following motion duly second by
councelor LJ Haywood mg Neil W stamp and
JC stilts uh councelor Fluker would you
like to table your
motion thank you chairman um chairman
this is uh quite a straightforward
motion and I'm sure the the members will
have seen the comments from members of
the public on online and on social media
and we have seen the article in in m and
Burnham chairman the whole idea of new
homes bonus really is to is to
compensate us chairman for uh uh the
disruption caused by hous new houses and
and and members will remember that you
know what I said previously that you
know the residents of hybridge in
particular have been eating dust for a
long long time now and chairman the real
purpose of the new homes bonus um is to
in my mind is to support infrastructure
I I agree with the government what the
government says that you can can use it
to support your councils or in our case
prop up the general fund chairman but I
actually see it as something else and I
know that the council is in a a shocking
position financially uh if members read
the reports that went to the last
meeting of strategy and resources they
will see the projections in the
medium-term financial strategy and of
course this would add to those problems
but if we address all of these issues
together the shortfall in the mtfs and
taking out the new homes bonus if we
start doing that now we really do have a
a chance that in a couple of years time
if that bonus is still coming into this
Council and it will be it can be spent
on infrastructure in everybody's Ward
which is what we need to do we need to
Prime some of these projects but
chairman I I I I I might be either
behind or ahead of myself chairman
because on the 24th of of January the
151 officer will remember that I sent
her an email uh it was marked up private
and conf credential uh and it basically
there were four items that I B up in
relation to the meeting the previous day
but I did mention the new homes bonus
because I couldn't actually hear it
mentioned in any of the reports that
went to that meeting uh there was talk
about the uh the uh the commercial one
but there was no talk about the new
homes bonus popping up the medium-term
financial strategy so chairman I'm
rather hopeful that the1 officer was
listen to the concerns of some
counselors and he's actually planning
not to to do that chairman but my my
motion remains on the table chairman
because I think we owe it to our
residents to spend that money on
infrastructure and I know my friends
opposite whose National Manifesto I've
read today support
infrastructure thank you councelor
Fluker I call upon Miss Lucas to respond
please um thank you chair um just for
members information just to provide a
little bit of context in terms of some
of the issues that Council Fluker has
raised um so members will be aware that
the council didn't manage to set a
balanced budget for this financial year
for 23
24 um and that was after the Assumption
of using new homes bonus to help um
balance the general fund expenditure for
the year so in in this financial year we
um will be receiving around £450,000 of
new homes bonus and that was agreed by
Council in February to help balance the
budget for this financial year so in
that respect it was not allocated to any
specific
projects um if this funding was agreed
to be rein fenced by Council for
particular projects this would have the
effect of increasing the budget Gap by
that same amount of £450,000 and just to
put that into a little bit of context
that equates to around nine um full-time
equivalent staff um based on an average
salary of 50k per anom which is roughly
the size of the whole housing team for
the council um so going into the next
financial year our working assumption is
again that the overall funding
settlement including any new homes bonus
allocation would be flat compared to
this year um even if the current new
homes bonus scheme is stopped or altered
because we haven't got a firm commitment
from government around the continuation
of that scheme currently um so again if
whatever funding we may be given through
new homes bonus next year was agreed to
be ring fence for particular projects
this would have the effect of increasing
the budget Gap by am that amount for
that next
year um central government has been
saying that is going to withdraw or
replace new homes bonus scheme for a
number of years now which has left us in
an in an uncertain position with regards
to our financial planning um the amounts
awarded each year have been going down
over time but a scheme is still
currently in place and there's no firm
announcement as I said for next year yet
um but the current Assumption of
government is that the core spending
power for the council does include the
use of new homes bonus to fund general
fund
Services um just to um give a bit of
context I don't think Council FL
actually referred to um business rates
but in the written motion that's
presented in your pack tonight there is
also reference to using some of the
business rates um to also um uh to to
allocate that for specific projects um
again just to provide um a little bit of
context around that um as members will
be aware um business rates are difficult
to accurately predict
and they can fluctuate year on year and
therefore the council has got a business
rates Equalization Reserve which was set
up to manage that
volatility so subsequently to setting
the budget in February and following a
review of the year and position um later
that year um the business rates position
for the last Financial year was slightly
better than forecast which enabled the
council then to top up that business
rates Equalization reserve and therefore
given the Gap as I say that we faced for
this Current financial year of £
421,000 it is recommended to council
that instead of calling on general fund
balances um that the business rate
Equalization Reserve is used for the
purpose that it was intended for um as I
say to manage that volatility and again
if the council chose to ring fence some
of those monies for alternative purposes
that would just have the same impact of
increasing the residual gap for this um
Financial year and would require as I
say the use of general fund balances to
then manage that position so I just
wanted to give that context um before
the debate and thank you thank you very
much indeed Miss Lucas um we'll open the
floor I've Got U councelor Paul as
spenley
please so um first of all I want to say
How Deeply touched I am by councilor
fluker's reference to hybridge and his
deep concern for all the residents who
who live there but based on that concern
I'm going to explain to him now why I
think this is such a bad
idea and that's because hybridge West as
I I believe is and and somebody can
correct me if I'm wrong the most
deprived ward in Moren district oh it
could be possibly mundan but there's a
bit bit of debate about that it's not
South MST I don't think but
anyway it's very deprived and because of
that um we rely very heavily um my
residents do upon um the services that
this Council provide
and actually what we're talking about
here in realistic terms is increasing
the budget the budget Gap and and making
more
cuts and I'll give you just a quick
example in the last few weeks and
councilor Burwood here will bear me out
in this and I hope that some of the
directors will as well a very near
flooding situation in haybridge was
averted by the help of one of our
officers that officer who I cannot name
in here because it wouldn't be
appropriate is on a temporary
contract and I know what will probably
happen to said officer with all her
expertise if if these Cuts had to be
made and I hope that we think about the
context properly I mean in my role as a
rep a District representative on the
health overview and scrutiny committee
at um Essex I recently found out for
example that we have more by far um
spent NHS section 106 monies than any
other District in the county and bearing
that in mind should we really be
thinking about cutting away our officer
resource at a time when we need our
officers to fight and push for that
infrastructure we've got projects in
this District which have not been
realized which should have been realized
long ago as a reporter I saw the
enthusiasm I had more hits on this than
any other story for the playground in
the sensory garden to be created from
section 106 money that has never come
forward so whilst I do appreciate the
very laudable Sentiments of councelor
fluka and he can come along and meet my
residents anytime he likes I have to say
I don't agree thank you chair thank you
Council spency councel Dar please did
you have your hand up councel Dar I did
thank you very much indeed my assistant
chairman um
new homes bonus was introduced in
2010 by the conservative liberal
Democrat
coalition
government uh and it was intended it was
introduced interestingly at the time
when the RSG started to be uh reduced so
I think it was a way that the government
intended to put money back into local
government in effect it was taking with
one hand and giving with the other
and it was under in the the sort of
thinly veiled reward for building new
houses that's where that's where um uh
new homes bonus came
from many authorities or some
authorities I should say were in a
financial position where they could ring
fence new homes bonus but many were not
the majority of authorities that didn't
have other income commercial income such
as molden
have to use the new homes bonus to
balance their books and
unfortunately had we been in a better
position we might have been able in the
past to have ring fenced um new homes
bonus for
um different projects but we're not in
that position and in fact um as Miss
Lucas has pointed out the future of new
homes bonus is far from certain and I
think that there is a good deal of um
speculation that it its days are
numbered and to be quite honest I think
they probably should be so unfortunately
we are in a position where we have to
retain the new homes bonus in order to
balance our books otherwise as Miss
Lucas has said we've got to find that
money from elsewhere strategy and
resources debated some very difficult
cuts and if we have to increase those by
another £400,000
plus it's going to be even more
unpalatable thank you councelor darham
councelor stem please yeah thank you
chairman um forgive me and everybody if
I've got incorrect facts I don't think
this council's balanced a budget for
quite some time they've always dipped
into the
reserves no yes whatever um so I
actually do agree with councelor fluca I
know that take on board exactly what
councelor spencley said but uh but the
NHS infrastructure money we have got no
control over how it's spent that's down
to the NHS so to me that's actually
quite a bit of a a red herring for this
debate the um I actually do agree we
should be putting money aside for the
infrastructure we are getting absolutely
zero mitigation of infrastructure in
many areas of this district and I feel
strongly that we are got to make Cuts we
should have made cuts years ago but we
didn't for whatever reason there wasn't
a balanced budget last year I'm sure
there wasn't no exactly because I think
somebody wanted to put an alternative
budget there wasn't a balanced budget
the year before there wasn't balanced
budget the year before which is
admirable now that we're starting to
actually look at having a balanced
budget but I do actually like to have
the facts straight if we're actually
trying to turn around and say that
somebody's trying to do something for
the benefit of others uh and I I agree
with councilor fluka yes there are going
to be some important cuts and if to turn
around and say it's so many housing
officers I could turn around and say
that money could be cut somewhere else
so that is a member decision when the
information is put forward at the
relevant committees for the votes to be
taken thank you chairman thank you
councelor stamp councelor White please
um thank you Mr chairman and I'm sorry
for keeping my coat on but I haven't
been well so I'm cold um just just to
come in um normally I I would want this
money to be ring fenced for
infrastructure but we are where we are
with the budget and it is a mess and
unfortunately I don't think we have any
option but to um use it to prop up the
budget much as I'm unhappy um and and
the problem with the budget budget we
talk about not balancing a budget but
the problem you get is one member or two
members will want one member of Staff
another two will want a different member
to stay and then you end up not cutting
any any posts or making any budget cost
at all I mean this year we've got 65,000
on a Gator and a mower um when I've been
asking for 5 years for a review of those
Services which has never happened um so
I say I think we've got no option um I'm
also concerned that we have to now bid
for funding for infrastructure and we
are down the bottom we are going to
receive nothing um highways have already
told me that we're in for nothing at
ferah or nothing anywhere else because
it's not considered worthy when we're up
against areas such as eeping um who have
more traffic and they're nearer to the
new traffic Corridor um so these are the
problems that we have and I would like
to make a a point going forwards that we
end up I'm sorry councel we do have to
bid with highways East and they've told
us that we are going to get no funding
um but um uh yeah I I think that in
future it needs to go forward for
infrastructure for our residents but I
think at this time unfortunately we have
no option um than to prop up the budget
much as I'm unhappy with it thank you um
councelor white councelor Morgan please
yeah thank you Mr chairman I mean um
whilst I say it's an extremely popular
proposal to ring fence this on behalf of
infrastructure but as councilor spencley
has so eloquently put it makes no
Financial sense whatsoever and therefore
I therefore say that the vot motion
should be voted down thank you thank you
very indeed
please uh thank you chairman I mean I I
do agree with the sentiments of council
fluke when the members supported it I
mean ideally we' like to see all of the
money that the council earns spent on
infrastructure and and and direct
service to the resence but we have to
function as a council as an organization
and that requires quite a lot of staff
that actually are not forward facing in
terms of the residence but I needed to
be there in the first place and Council
Dar was correct I mean the the SCH was
originally introduced really just to you
promote the if you like the incentive to
to build new homes but but also to bring
back empty homes back into play it was
supposed to be on play for six years now
it's just dragging on each year and
really all the government are going to
do is they're probably going to I've
looked at the consultations so they keep
saying well should it be linked to the
local development plan and if you don't
meet your target should it be reduced
and all this sort of stuff they're
obviously looking for ways out of it but
they can't just take the money away it
probably just be called something else
um and not new home boner so whilst I
support the the if feel like intent of
the motion I don't think as a counil
that we in that position to do it if we
continue to make the savings that we
were striving to do then at some point
in time then we hopefully will have a
surplus of funds that we can directly
put back in the community but until we
reach that point we can't make it happen
just by taking the money away so I
couldn't support it for that reason
thank you councelor FK councelor
Thompson please um thank you chairman um
actually previous administrations have
made huge efforts to balance the budget
and not take money out of reserves uh
one was our transformation project which
was in fact largely led by councilor
fluka himself that has I admit had mixed
results but since then newer members
have been trying to unravel that and put
things back the way they
were this is just not sustainable it is
a lovely idea I agree with everyone who
said it's a lovely idea but it's also
high in the sky we can't keep taking
money out of reserves it's not a
bottomless pit and the more we do it the
sooner we arrive at the bottom of the of
said Barrel thank you thank you very
much C Dar well thank you just for
clarity I've just researched um the
Secretary of State's comments on the
launch of um the new homes bonus in 2011
actually when it became lore and this
was the background to this was the um
the lowest um the lowest rate of new
building during the previous labor
government when the conservative liberal
Democrat government came in in 2010 they
Ed no home um the new homes bonus in
order to increase the rate of building
but it actually says the new homes bonus
is a key part of a wider framework of
incentives to support growth the
community infrastructure Levy is a way
of ensuring that development is
supported with adequate infrastructure
it's not new homes bonus it was sill
that was introduced at the same time in
the same bill that was envisaged to
produce the infrastructure thank you
thank counc
D Council
driver uh thank you chair uh since the
sill has been mentioned I will mention
it
again and unfortunately this Council
tried in 2017 and then again in 2020 to
achieve Sil we spent money
uh with Consultants to try and Achieve
that and sadly we didn't achieve it so
there was a large sum of money that was
potentially there that we weren't able
to achieve now that's looking backwards
and it's sad that that happened but
that's where we are so I would just
reiterate councilor spenley point I find
it very difficult to see how we can take
£450,000 out of the budget without being
really clear
where we are going to make Cuts now it
might be that councilor fluka has up his
sleeve uh where those cuts are going to
come from um but at the moment a lot of
effort has been put into looking at the
budget and looking at how we try and
balance that budget and at the moment
unless we re revisit that and go through
a very difficult process of finding some
more Cuts £450,000
worth which will impact on residents
it's not as if that we're not going to
impact on them we will significantly
impact on our residents if we do that
you know perfectly well councilor Fluker
that actually we are very committed to
infrastructure very committed to it but
it's got to work we can't just simply
slash the rest of the uh Council budget
and impact on many many residents in
order to achieve this particular aim
thank you thank coun driver I think it's
also important just as a comment from me
cutting is is is quite simple has the
consequences sometimes that are not um
anticipated but also growth needs to be
looked at um you need to prune
significantly to let the new growth come
through so it's it's both councelor
Fluker I think everybody's spoken who
wants so you have the right to come back
and be the final speaker on your
motion yeah thank you chairman I I I
mean look most s really uh provide the
opportunity for for all members uh to to
debate this the subjects at hand and and
I think chairman you'd have to agree
with me that in this case that part of
the motion or the reason of the motion
has actually succeeded but I fear for
the rest of it um chairman just just as
a just as a point because you know it is
a very very difficult issue that
councilor spenc brought up can I just
refer you to uh the the planning
application in southminster for the new
Pavilion and the response from uh M
District Council based on National
statistics southminster sadly regardless
of all my hard work is in the lowest 20%
of uh of council areas as far as I
always get it wrong deprivation
deprivation is concerned chairman I I I
would also say chairman that when I was
in the political leadership of this team
of this Council we we actually produce
some very large purposes councelor Dar
myself did by budgeting properly and
fairly and and we delivered Services as
well so I know it can be done a million
pound well chairman thank you chairman I
did write down the million pounds but I
you know I didn't want to Big him up too
much I think I only succeeded in 800,000
um but chairman this is all to do with
aspirations we've we've heard tonight um
I think by from the1 officer on
councelor Durham that the new homes
bonus is soon to go um Mr Gove by the
way um was speaking about it the week
before last on on one of the Sunday uh
programs uh saying that Council should
be using new home bonus for um uh
delivering infrastructure projects but
that's Mr Goen he's probably got a
different uh argument today but the
whole idea of this is is to is to try
and make us all think about alternative
budgets and what we're going to try and
do now we can't based on what we've been
told tonight we can't incl include the
new homes bonus in the mtfs
uh from year two and three looking
forward um it appears to me um that we
really don't know whether we're going to
get this I suspect we won't it'll
probably be dressed up in something else
and it all be lost to to other people uh
as part of the uh countywide whatever it
is
um the other thing is Chairman we keep
talking about we can't take out 456,000
quid out the
budget but how many people in this
chamber actually
know how much it costs to buy
nonstatutory and discretionary charges
I've been banging on about having a
costed uh corporate plan that got lost
that got lost in the ether of the
committee system and something Council
white and I have had a discussion about
because it was agreed Council fluka just
to remind you you're just summing up and
your time I am sing
up I haven't had the benefit to listen
to the the the tape yet but these are
all things that people have touched on
so I think I can mention it well within
the time duly given to you within the
contition I've almost finished I've
almost finished but chairman I hear what
you say about costs and I hear about
what you say about cut Cuts chairman but
the latest uh authority to declare
itself skin was Nottingham today and
they've had they've admitted that they
should have started this process
properly five or six years ago we don't
have adult and children social care
affected us we don't have any strange uh
uh projects on the go like Thor chairman
uh you know I I I accept and and and
totally respect all the comments made on
this but it's a bigger picture chairman
and it's something we should be thinking
about it's no good saying we've got a
budget now we're going to be fine in
three years time 1.5 million pound
deficit believe me will go to 2.5
million pounds even if the interest
rates dropped by two points chairman
I've put my motion and thank you very
much indeed councilor fluka um members
um the motion's been put the motion's
been debated so therefore I call for
those in favor of the motion is that
seconded thank you recorded vote Tara
has been requested by councelor fluka
seconded by councelor
stamp thank you chairman thank you are
you happy for me to go ahead and take
that certainly thank you very
much me you for the the
motion as B if you could indicate for
against or obain when I call your name
please start councel B
against
against Bell here sorry counc Bell oh
sorry apologies coun sorry counc
against thank you Council against counc
B
against Council
driver
against counc Dar again against councel
F against councel
Fluker councelor hywood
for councelor
Jennings against councelor lag abstain
please Tara councel L
against councel label
against councelor Miller
against councelor Morgan
against councelor Neil
for councelor Pratt against councel
sha against councelor Sid
against councel Sid
Norman councel Nick spenley against
councel Paul spenley against counc stamp
for Council
Stevens
against councelor sils
for councelor Swindle
against councelor Thompson
against
White against but only because the
budget's so
bad thank you coun
with
against thank you chairman the results
of that are six for 21 against and one
abstention thank you chairman thank you
very much indeed so that motion fails so
thank you members a very robust debate
we move on to agenda item 10 which is
questions in accordance with procedure
rle 6 three of which notices have been
given I have not been given any so we
move on to item 11 which is the
Southeastern area planning committee
management which is found on your agenda
papers 19 to 26 and members follow an
adjournment at the council meeting on
the 14th of September 2023 minute number
246 refers minute extract enclosed to
resume debate on the report of the
director of strategy and resources
there's a copy enclosed the member uh as
as discussed at the agenda meeting there
was two proposals made in September and
they will still stand and they were
seconded so those proposals were they're
found on page 19 uh little one that
members note the findings from the
review and the issue set out in section
3.7 of the report and two that members
confirm the preferred option for future
meetings as set out in point 3 3.8 of
three report and before I move further
Mr Dodson have you anything to add thank
you thank you chair um I'm not going to
reintroduce the paper because it was was
debated and deferred um at the previous
meeting of council however ahead of the
debate resumption um I did want to give
the the latest view of officers on the
the southeast area planning
Arrangements the resource given to this
work by it and corporate staff is
continuing to to impact the delivery of
other corporate priorities as we
continue to troubleshoot the poor
quality setup for live
streaming we've had two meetings of the
southeast area planning take place since
the 14th of September that were recorded
and published days after the meeting not
live streamed they also had technical
difficulties for live participants
including a request for a public
participant to dial in that had to be
advised the technology wasn't possible
for this
during the day of the 15th of November a
senior member of Our IT staff an MDC
committee clerk the Burnham Clerk and
the external it contractor for Burnham
all had their resources diverted in
attempt to problem solve that the
cameras weren't working when tested um
this would have prevented the meeting
recording this is a frequent problem as
the space is used regularly and
Equipment can be knocked or or touched
by people using the room and this can
affect the setups
at the council meeting on the 14th of
September it was advised by members that
burnam it staff were installing
broadband and the debate was deferred to
allow for a solution to be put in
place molden District Council staff have
been in regular contact with Burnham
staff who have attempted to address the
Broadband provision but unfortunately
internet suppliers have been unable to
locate or confirm ability to set this up
at the site as it stands all details set
out in the original report around the
difficulty running the meetings at
Burnham toown Council highlighted in
section 3.7 of the report and the work
required to address this stand as per
the 14th of September report to
council and are continuing to
increase um despite the reassurances
that this would be addressed and solved
by bur Burnham on Crouch it support um
and that they would find a a solution to
increase Broadband capacity this hasn't
happened as as I said our understanding
from the the burnam on Crouch it support
is that there are no further plans to
address the issues and even if Broadband
capacity was addressed there's still a
requirement for local support and a
sound system in place which doesn't seem
to be on the work plate plan for Burnham
IT staff and the ongoing issue that
equipment is often Disturbed leading to
setup
issues the meeting on the 15th of
November Illustrated that the situation
is declining and resulted in a large
loss of source for molden District
Council both in working hours and
outside of regular hours and also
resulted in an extremely poor service
for residents and members we ask that a
solution is found today to prevent any
further issues section 3.8 of the report
sets out three options for members
consideration to confirm a future
approach for meetings of the southeast
area committee members are asked to keep
in mind this update and the draw that
continues on MDC resources whilst
reviewing the options if we're to
continue streaming from Burnham Town
Council as shown in option two resource
to support these meetings a cost to the
council's budget will need to be put in
place thank you chair thank you very
much indeed Mr dson members we need
know Clarity or point of order
Clarity uh what is your point please
just first it would be useful to have
that verbal
report
it's
particularly um it's in on page 22
bullet number two um chairman I that's
not really a point of
clarity you have the right to come in
part of the debate it is Chairman
because it says it says in on the right
hand side on the right hand side in
bullets and I think this is important um
it says an additional 45k perom required
to for MDC ICT officer chman that seems
like huge amount of money but chairman I
queried this with Miss Hughes and and
and she just referred me back to the
report and we don't know what that
45,000 is for so how on Earth can we
make make an informed decision well when
when I when if you if you decide to join
the debate I'll call for you and you may
be asked that question but we have other
members who hands have been up and
councelor Bell
please thank you um Mr chair we have
today an update from um Burnham toown
Council and um that update says that
they've now commenced work to upgrade
the internet connection so I'm not
entirely sure where um Mr dodson's
information comes
from the uh if not in place by December
it will certainly be in place for um
January that required upgrade and um BTC
also which I think is very kind have
offered um a proposed cost saving of £60
for the room higher um which will be the
removal for of the provision of a staff
member um because we can actually use
the key safe and um and um let ourselves
in and they will set everything up for
us in the afternoon before they leave so
in light of this information and the
importance
of democracy and holding the meetings
locally and I think that's evidenced by
the number of people we get attending
the meetings at Southeast I would like
to propose members that we go for option
two which is to retain the service thank
you thank you Mr chairman who second
that councelor white I believe in you
thank you we have other speakers um
we've got councelor stamp next please
yeah thank you chair um obviously
councilor Bell and I have spoken and I
recognize everything she said because it
was me who was chasing for it I don't
recognize what Mr Dodson said I would
actually ask when the last time they
actually spoke to the officers at
Burnham Town Council we all know that
this Council has tried to remove this
planning um area planning committee to
this chamber for years it comes up nigh
on every six months or at least every
year every time it's been successfully
voted down because we're great Believers
in local democracy I think this Council
and this C this Council needs to be
cautious because I watch some of the
area planning committees that are run
from this chamber and they are often
badly recorded themselves so in my in my
words people in Glass Houses really
shouldn't throw stones I attended a
meeting two me meetings this week where
we couldn't hear properly when things
were live streamed from this chamber so
I think we really do need to be cautious
about saying that Burnham live streaming
or Burnham is is below par because this
Council does not want it to come back
here I strongly ruit what Mr Dodson has
said because I don't think the check the
facts have been checked and updated
before this meeting and I would have
expected the members to be given the
latest
information like what councilor Bell and
I chased this afternoon and we got got
it at 4 4:16 I think it was when we got
the message through and we have been
working closely with Burnham Town
Council to represent our residents and I
certainly I have put on this report
chair and you'll have to forgive me and
I will say I've put rubbish on many
occasions because I don't agree with
what this report says um and I think
they've turned around and reduced the
staff cost of60 which I think is
generous I don't actually agree with the
figures and I certainly don't agree with
the number of people where it states
we've had five people three people one
people people person sorry chair um so
I'm afraid Mr Dodson I hope I haven't
upset you or offended you um but I do
not support uh what this recommendation
and this officer's report says and I do
refute it and I'm sorry I'm shaking I
haven't eaten all day and it's it's
actually now having that effect on me so
I do apologize I've got shakes thank you
thank you very much C stamp I think Mr
doson please thank you
chair it is disappointed when the
officers prepare reports based on their
technical knowledge and the best
information that is available to them so
I find it very disappointing if if
members refer to it as rubbish because
it absolutely isn't it's the
professional views of those members who
officers who are directly involved in it
um in terms of the the latest
information shared by councelor Bell
that is n consistent with the the latest
information we received two officers
from from Burnham Town Council um there
hasn't been a dialogue between officers
and and that that Council today so I've
only been able to present on the latest
information that that was available to
officers and which which they shared
with me which was based what what they
based their professional opinions on
which I presented at the start thank you
thank you very much Mr dson uh councilor
y please um thank you Mr chairman well I
mean this this for me is democracy I
mean the the meetings have been held in
the chamber in Burnham certainly since
I've been elected and were well in
underway then and I've just looked at
the figures and the quote for 45,000 for
a planning officer or an IT officer to
be at the meetings works out at a cost
of
£3,750 per meeting if that's one meeting
every 12 months well I think I could
find a contractor to do that way cheaper
if there were any problems cuz that's a
huge sum of money
um and just to say that at the recent
strategy and resources meeting which
started at 700 p.m. um nobody could get
the it to work because the it officers
don't come into the chamber anymore so
nobody can get it to work and they went
oh well hopefully it will just work at
half past 7 so it's not just confined to
Burnham and I also think that the I only
get emails really for rubbish and um
planning and I think we must keep these
area planning committees and this is
this is another one of that's important
so let's please keep keep it in burnam
thank you councelor white councelor
darham please well I um
chairman it matters not to me personally
about Burnham which is fine um that's
for other members to decide if it's a
question of insufficient
bandwidth has anybody thought about
starlink satellite which is available
across highspeed internet that doesn't
rely on any cabling um and I'm sure Elon
Musk will
it it I'm sure it will entertain him of
an evening watching Southeast planning
uh through his system but it is
something perhaps that could be
considered well I don't know how to
respond to that so I probably
won't councelor Thompson
please um well thank you chairman um I'd
have to be bit more serious after that I
wish I didn't serious given the um of
course councelor don't um given the
discussion we've just had on the new new
homes bonus motion I'm afraid I've got
to say that any saving is a saving and
we need to make it if there's any hope
ever for that that particular aspiration
so unless someone can show me the actual
savings by holding it at Burnham as
opposed to costs I remain unconvinced as
regards local democracy we are all here
when we sit as local planning Authority
we're all here to represent the whole
District not our Wards not our local
residents the whole district and also
poor old Northwest the people in tlsb
and Wick and Bishops and all around our
area where where we're based up north
they don't have local local democracy
not in that sense they feel it's right
they come to molden if they want to and
I just can't see any expenditure for
what a maximum of 13 people who might
for all we know live in latchington and
be near a molden than they are to burn
them I mean who knows so I'm afraid with
that lot added together I couldn't
support keeping it at burn thank you
thank councel Thompson councelor bound
please you're up yeah now I was only
well really I was only going to re re
reemphasize what council Bell said but
um the message from the chief officer of
Burnham toown cast was that um it will
be def definitely the word was
definitely if it's not December it
definitely be January will be upgraded
the system and then the other thing is
about the the costing the 45,000 I do
agree what council said that seems
Preposterous amount and how how have you
come to that amount okay thank you counc
B there was a question in there how they
come to that amount I don't really think
that can be
answered have
I uh Mrs Mrs card's
online who who should be able to answer
that question okay thank you Mr D Mrs
cardi
if we can get the connection
through good
evening
evening did you hear the question from
councilor
bound
repeat very councel bound could you
repeat the question about the 45,000
please yes how did you get to £45,000 a
year to run the meeting uh in Burham
Burham toown Council chamber pardon it
for an IT officer yeah thank you seems
um incredibly
high thank um it is based on .6 of um an
FTE it results an expert um it does
include the actual salary Cost Plus on
cost as which is what full cost would be
um it's based on the number of hours
that we have provided it expertise for
over the course of the meetings being at
beron um if this option is agreed on we
can revie that U amount of cost but um
it will have to be a cost because um
unless obviously it bur take over the
management of this um there have been
many attempts
to Ure that we do get a full service an
IT service but the the problems remain
and that
is outside hour last minut so that does
inflate the cost to have somebody
always thank you thank you very much
indeed M cardi to answer your question
Council B well not really um it's um I
mean I mean you're telling me so how
many hours are we talking about per
meeting for this it person to to then
sort of get it down to um what the alley
rate is seems incredibly highly High
alley
rate come you certainly okay Mr
Dodson thank you thank you chair I think
that also includes the the um expertise
and the input from people like the lead
specialist it who who's been drawn on to
to resolve this issue so it isn't purely
one member of staff that that's been um
dealing with this it's drawn on the team
to date so so that's included within
that calculation thank you Mr thank you
very much indeed uh um councelor Sid
Norman
please thank
you I have got on this Council in
1995 and you've been trying to do this
in buron for that length of
time now it's my idea that councils
aren't just about budgets they're about
people's
lives in our area we are very proud of
our denji we are very the people are
very proud of the denji and they're very
proud of their planning laws and their
and their um opinions of what goes on
and one of the things that they do they
come to the Burnham Town Council which
is the center of our Deni actually
to give their points of view residents
not just counselors to tell people what
they want to the council to know before
they
vote now to get there they have to use a
car most of them because the Deni is
quite a large
area now we're not just talking about
budgets we're talking about
environmentally friendly
situations we actually at the end of the
day if if we really wanted to we could
go to um and and get rid of everything
here and go to
chelsford but we're
not and we don't want that to happen in
Burnham either so I I ask you to put
your all all your um ideas on
budgets to the value of the environment
people's
cars and their self-esteem as to whether
they actually
own what happens in their district and
they voice it at Burnham and they don't
want to voice it at molden thank you
very much thank you very much indeed
councelor Sid Norman uh councelor fit
please uh thank you chair I mean it's a
difficult one I agree with the officers
at the end of the day you can't just
throw money down a pit forever and I
understand how the costs of calculate
they're based upon what we've happened
in the past but obviously if a solution
is found that is efficient in terms of
the Broadband speed and the the the
sound then the cost won't be that number
that's quoted in report moving forward
so this is really looking at if you
don't do anything this is what is going
to cost the council I remember watching
a video from ESS County council at the
local Highway panel and I think it was a
no through sign was something like
£40,000 wasn't it to put a sign up
because of all the process you go
through to get it officer time and going
for the local panel so sometimes things
cost a lot more than we would think they
would do if we were doing it ourself
that's just the way that councils work
it can't be avoided so I think the
problem is is that we're in this
conundrum now we we've got the the burn
mon outand they can resolve the problem
and we've got a report in front of it
that speaks historically to the cost we
don't know what the cost will be moving
forward um the question is I suppose how
long do we wait to find that point of
view out I mean is it necessary that we
do this right this minute we've taken
the view that potentially we won't do
the sound recordings and the video
streams at Burham uh Southeast Planet
until such point in time that we have a
solution or not a solution so I I I
don't think to look at the report and
say it's going to cost this moving
forward is a fair reflection on the risk
that we face in the future and and and
counc nor was right is value for money
is not about not spending money it's
about spending money on things that
people value and I do think there is
significant feeling amongst Burnham
which is one of our second largest town
and around the denji area I'm either
moving out s of ply and cold Orton that
it being at burum is a significant event
now whether tradition's right or wrong
that has been a tradition and I'm not
entirely sure for a few
thousands the perception that we're
going to get from doing it is right
we've also we should bear in mind got
potential emotions coming forward in the
future in terms of cost savings that
might end up as as having one area
planning committee which being the case
then there will be no area planning
committees and it won't be a burden so
that resolve the problem so I just think
that we're forcing oursel into position
to make decision with information that
might change for very little reason than
okay thank you very much indeed
councelor Morgan
please uh yes thank you chair could I
through you ask um Mr Dodson would I be
right in
in assuming that option three is the
most cost effective option going
forward you can yes that would be great
thank you I've obviously heard the
arguments about um democracy and Etc I
understand all that but I would just add
or say this is molden not Montana and
the distance between here and Burnham is
is not that great and therefore in view
of the dire um budgetary problems we
face I move that we adopt option three
we already have a mo we have a
motion we already got so apologies have
that thank you uh next I've got uh counc
Pratt
please thank you chairman
um there are lots of pros and cons but
what disappoints me having been
there for quite some time um is how few
people actually turn up and we have it
recorded it's 11 here it's 5 here and
some counselors
say
members did you want to say something I
I'll give wait to coun no no I just I
was just curious what you said chairman
um chairman because um councel Pratt
hasn't been to all meetings since he's
since he's been so I'm not sure how he'd
know but just to let him know the last
two if he wasn't there there was 11 at
one and 10 at the other uh chairman if I
may um having being four years where I
wasn't a District counselor I watched
virtually every
meeting um yes I have missed a
couple um however we have the evidence
here that people turn don't turn up um
and at the last meeting where there was
11 several of them were agents that
weren't burn people they were agent
representing people were come from
lington um but the main point I wanted
to say is we seem to be being asked to
make a decision on a system that doesn't
work I I would happily propose that we
defer this yet again until Burnham get a
system that works
um I I watched our last meeting which I
was there councilor Fluker um and you
could hardly hear members speak there
was a dreadful humming like an earth
fault that was constantly going members
are led to believe that we have black
microphones on the table that people
lean towards that's not even connected
into the system it's for the hearing
Loop um those black mics don't work with
uh this system that we've got when you
look at the other planning meetings it
is much C more crystal clear but how we
can make a decision based on what we've
got at the moment with promises for next
December or January perhaps we could
make the
decision when it works we can then look
at it whether it's feasible and if it
doesn't work I think a lot of people
watch it and we should make a decision
when the the new broadband system is
working thank you chairman thank you
very much indeed um Miss cardi would
like just to come back and and impart
some further information so I call upon
Miss cardi
please thank you chair thank you um I
think um the problem that you say say is
that the um internet and sound are not
working um and as we carry on the
resource is taken from our it and our
other um areas to to help try to make
the the meetings as as good as possible
or we also recognize the number of
issues so I would say that if we don't
um if we do carry on with those meetings
that results will still be pulled from
our teams and it will have a direct
impact on on the corporate resources
that we are trying to deliver and I
think you're all aware of the importance
of that on the savings and the budget
position and things that we need to do
for business as usual as well as savings
option um and
being money as we can so I do have some
concerns about the results that we will
need to carry on with this uh without
the resolutions I I do note that from
the last meeting we had it was um
it was uh vocalized that we would have a
Broadband solution in place by burn MIT
staff within four weeks we have passed
that deadline and I still um have not
heard a date which we would have band
unless I've missed it apologies um and
even so if that was the case and it was
resolved there was still the sound issue
that we don't currently have a
resolution for so I think we're all
share the same concerns that the
customer service that we provided is not
adequate and we are all very concerned
about that and additionally I'm
concerned about the result that is
required to carry on um these meetings
that are not meeting our quality
standards so um I would ask that if we
could um provide
an option um of one of those three
options if that could be made a decision
on we could actually move forward a
[Music]
more thank you thank you indeed Miss
cardi um members I've got some members
who haven't spoken yet so I'm going to
go to those members then I'll afford the
courtesy of of a very quick comeback for
some members who have spoken but we we
it will be very quick comeback um so
councelor Stevens
please thank you chair um I agreed with
everything that councelor fit said and
that everything that councelor Pratt
said um it it doesn't feel right to
wrench this away from people and it
isn't about just never spending any
money it is about spending it correctly
um but at the same time this seems to be
ongoing and ongoing and we want another
day we want another four weeks we want
another bit we want another bit I
wouldn't be averse to pushing this
decision back to another meeting but I
think we've really got to put a deadline
on it firmly agree a deadline today and
stick to it and come what may we don't
go past that deadline thank you very
much we do we do have a recommendation
on the table so that has been seconded
so we will go for that recommendation um
once we finish the debate uh councelor
Haywood
please I'm attempt to stand up no I'll
Stand Up
really actually obviously I was in here
yesterday on a licensing meeting and we
couldn't stream it didn't work so um
that was half an hour it took about 10
minutes to try and get us up and running
so it doesn't work what I'd like to see
obviously I've been looking at the
figures for running it from Burnham how
much did it cost to run it from here
because we must have an IT person on
there at the moment so that's costing us
so how much do all our meetings like a
planning meeting cost from here because
we should have that because you're
saying 45,000 from Burnham but how much
do it cost us to run a planning meeting
from here so we should that should be on
the um the report to say how much it's
going to cost us and it doesn't so what
are our cost from this building because
if it's almost the same then we might as
the start burn them which is what
everyone
wants thank you very much indeed do we
have those costs or is it something we
could share later Mr doson thank you um
thank you I I don't have the the costs
to hand it was my understanding that
these were additional costs though over
and above the cost of of operating the
meeting normally but but I will but I
will um qualify that that I would like
to to check an
addition the report does stay
additional thank you very much indeed
councelor stilts please thank you Mr
chairman um councelor Haywood has said
some of what I was going to say and
yesterday's meeting was terrible we
could not live stream it we couldn't
record it and I believe Mr quelch said
that it wasn't legally required to
record that meeting um so we are talking
about a legal requirement to recall
planning or not so that would be one
question the other thing is I have
complained several times where I've
listened to the YouTube recordings of
these meetings you can't hear counselors
the mics don't work we were in a meeting
the other day um on teams you could hear
a counselor in this room but you could
only hear every other word of what she
was saying so when we're looking at
Burnham's recordings being really poor
why are we not looking at this it as
well than Mr qu please let me just uh um
it is right what councelor stilt said
but she's taking me out of context
um and context is very important uh that
was in the context of whether the
meeting could actually go ahead legally
and I'm sure councelor durren will will
confirm that the council has made
resolutions about matters of streaming
live streaming and recordings on YouTube
that's a different issue to what's
legally required in relation to the
licensing committee there was a hiccup
Council Durham as the chair wanted to
know whether the meeting could go ahead
legally without recording so the context
of my statement isn't relevant to what's
been said in this
chamber thank you for clarifying that Mr
Mr
Dodson thank you chair um I just wanted
to make a a couple of observations one
is that I think overall the quality of
streaming and recording from this
chamber
generally meets the the the the quality
standards that that the council looks
for and sets yes there are isolated um
incidents when when things go wrong and
they're addressed and um the the team
address them so I think it's it's really
important not to not to
undermine the the issues that we're
talking about the issues are the quality
from Burnham and the cost and the report
makes no comment on the the de
Democratic discussion on on the the
merits of whether it should be there for
those local reasons at at um burnam on
Crouch it simply sets out the issues
with the quality of the streaming that
this Council set out that they wanted to
provide for every meeting that the
council runs and the and it gives
explains the the issues and sets out
options to deliver what the council
agreed it would deliver thank you chair
thank you very much indeed okay so we'll
just go back for some some follow-up
questions but please members can we can
I've got you down councelor fluka um
could I actually yes councilor fluka you
are next on my list thank you well done
CH it's in such a long time um look Mr
quch is absolutely absolutely right but
of course you know if there is no live
stream in this in in this chamber or any
chamber or wherever um and the planning
Authority is sitting then the meeting
must go ahead otherwise I fear that we
will be uh appealed against for
non-determination unless we can do it
quickly I think it also look clearly
there's two chains of information coming
forward here um I popped into the
council offices last week and I checked
the upload download speeds and the Ping
latency and everything else and it did
look pretty good to me clearly there may
be an issue with Hardware but look
you've got to understand that Mr
dodson's report and a lot of what he
said tonight is based on something that
goes back to the middle of September
which is added to this evening it would
have been good if we'd got an update and
also I think Miss cardi was reading from
something so if she had a report or
something that might have been useful
but I I still don't I bought this up as
a matter of clarity right at the
beginning about this 45,000 quid I mean
we've we've heard from Miss Cary that
it's point six of an FTE which means
basically we've got a starting s we have
somewhere around about 98
999,000 6 of that um later we heard that
this was certain amount of wage
contributions from several people but
chairman I I I really just wanted to
drill into some of these costs because I
think it's really really important um um
so I mean £6,000 to purchase a category
6 cable does seem a huge amount of money
likewise
£525 to to install it I mean if you want
a cat six um cable put in anywhere
chairman it's it's certainly not those P
um the other thing the other thing
chairman the uh sorry you there yeah um
it it talks in here chairman that M
District Council are going to support
Burnham Burnham Town Council on the
whole of their it Provisions now if that
is the case and it does sound to me as
it's moved on so this report again
probably needs amending um that would be
chargeable so we should be actually
charging them if we're actually doing
all their it work for them it does seem
and I go back to the 14th September it
does seem that this was written some
time ago and since then things have
moved forward I think chairman the
45,000 pounds I mean I think this is I'm
very confused first of all Mr Dudson
said that was looking backwards now we
say it's looking ahead as per the report
but I don't really think that anybody
can really believe that this meeting
tonight is costing £35,000 for it it
makes no and that's what that equates to
12 meetings at that PR £35,000 per
meeting and and chairman I I think the
uh so I think we've dealt with chairman
the government governance over this and
about whether or not it's right and
proper to adjourn meetings um to I think
everybody makes good points I I think I
think that the council the planning
meetings have been held there since 1976
and up until June I mean in June last
year I think there was about 186 Brit
people streamed the meeting and then
since then it all seemed to go backwards
but you're quite right we have been
looking at this for quite some time my
view is Chairman for for the for the
municipal year chairman I think there's
only three or four meetings left I mean
I know you've got an option on the table
maybe we do need to re revisit this but
not until we've got some firm actual
defendable costs because clearly there's
something wrong in the costing tonight
uh and it may be chairman that we defer
this until the start of the next
Municipal year but we really do need to
do something I think thank you coun I'm
GNA move to I said councelor Kevin
Jennings and my apologies Kevin Mr
Jennings councelor Jennings because uh
you haven't spoken so could you yeah um
yeah um in response to councelor Stevens
councelor Pratt and what councilor fluk
was just saying there definitely has to
be a deferral um some of the um options
here aren't entirely relevant at this
time since many months have passed and
Technology does does change quite
considerably being a shop manager on
molden High Street my Broadband is awful
so I can rarely take a uh A team's
meeting to my um head office which is
disappointing as well so the problem
does exist the problem is very real um
as councilor Bell has received latest um
information regarding January as a
possible setup I think we should defer
it until such time and then we can get a
further update and see whether things
have changed um at all with with the
streaming services
available um yeah that's that's all I
have to say there is a deferral definite
thank you very much indeed councelor
Daren just a short yeah thank you I will
be very short councelor Thompson sort of
inferred I was making a um a flippant
comment um Starling is available in
Burnham cost about 400 quid for the
equipment and is £75 a month which gets
you between 40 and 200 megabits a second
so there you are can we just get this in
perspective please you've got the
figures there all year at Burnham the we
had a Baker's Dozen people attending
physically 187 views on the YouTube
streaming that's a maximum Northwest
couple of occasions this year have
already have had in excess of 30 or 40
and might we had a big turnout from
tulsy recently and I've just been
looking uh so the views for Northwestern
Committee in SE in September 495 views
that was double what the district
planning committee had sitting the week
before and again even more than the
council meeting so I'm afraid these
figures show that not many people turn
up physically nor actually view it on
YouTube in comparison so you know let's
just let's just get a grip of this and
get a handle on on on the the the
context please because of course it's
important to people in Burnham but
clearly not that
important thank you councelor Tompson uh
sorry councel Thompson's next
sorry thank you chairman I'd like to
apologize through you to council darum I
didn't mean to suggest he was being
flippant but he did manage to raise a
laugh with his comment which is more
than I was able to do um I've going to
say streaming is key to all our meetings
and therefore the quality matters and it
is better when we're here I mean the
fact is in 1976 and most of the time
since then everything was different we
had no streaming for a start so if you
wanted to hear a planning planning
meeting you had to attend it in person
more people had cars have cars now than
then so it was that much more difficult
to go further back then now as Council
Durham's pointed out far more people
watch online than turn up in person
possibly the reason that Southeast
speakers are so low for watching on Zoom
is because the quality is so poor i'
I've tried and failed I've noticed with
the standards set up there you can't
even see which member is speaking
necessarily there's at least two near
who are near the top table who can't be
seen can't be
identified so I would actually say my my
own View and I'm not going to try and
make it a proposal because we've got so
many to get through um actually I think
Southeast should come back here until it
can be demonstrated that it can be
streamed properly from Burnham okay not
the other way around thank you thank you
very much indeed coun Sid
Norman thank
you thank
you well they say that you shouldn't
make a decision you've already already
made up your mind about my mind's been
made up for 30 years
that in fact that burnam is my the
important part for the planning um um
meetings to be and I I I ask you all to
understand that sometimes what we
believe and what we really is important
to us is more important than money thank
you thank you very much indeed I just
have two more members I've got councelor
stamp and then we'll finish with
councelor Bell please yeah thank you I
think it's just ingenuous what um
councelor Durham said he most probably
had a contentious issue at one of his
area planning committees I've sat and
watched his area planning committees
like he has most everybody else's area
planning committees so I could actually
watch mainly to see if the it is working
to get evidence against what I was
standing up to say tonight um whether
you agree with it or not councel Durham
or anybody else burnam on crou residents
and the
18,200 divisional members that I
represent a lot of them want to keep it
there whether they choose to watch it
is is down to them and I don't take on
board what you said about the number of
people that attend I've been there when
it's been absolutely rmo over the years
because of uh planning applications so
it's easy to Cher a pick yet again what
suits you when it suits you to say it I
don't support it being moved and I won't
support it being moved we are
democratically elected and we're
representing our residents and if this
Council choose to move it move it based
on the evidence that we've got tonight
or the report which we've approved
wasn't up to date the information wasn't
up to date and if you're going to ask
people to actually move and make
decisions based on evidence it really
should have had an amendment or what's
it called when you get the the thing
coming up addendum or whatever is coming
up later um um and I'm I'm going to shut
up there because I think it's very
obvious don't be rude thank you
councelor Bill and then we finish the
debate thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you everybody who has contributed
um to the debate I think we've
established a few things we've
established that unfortunately officers
didn't have the most upto-date
information when the report was uh
written that can't be helped and we did
have last minute
information we've established the it
offices our wonderful it team work from
home they're not here they're remote so
there's no additional cost for them
going to Burnham because they're not
here and thirdly we've established that
meetings here are not streamed in high
quality fashion and indeed sometimes s
often there are major issues with the
meetings being streamed here so just
taking all those factors together I
can't see a legitimate reason for moving
it so I maintain my position that we
should go for option two and keep the
meetings at Burnham as we now have a
guarantee from uh the staff at Burnham
that we're going to have the it in place
that we need thank you very much thank
council members we've had very robust
and long debate on this issue so we've
got two recommendations on the report um
I'd like to take them separately if
that's okay the first you already got a
proposal that was seconded by councel
Bell that was the first one yeah but it
we got to do first one not it but but
that was The Proposal that's only a
recommendation so the propos it is
actually coun Bill's proposal which was
sort supported by councilor stamp was
it yeah thank you very much indeed Clark
um chairman just wanted to draw your
attention there were the proposals made
at the previous meeting discussion on
this there was proposal by yourself that
put the recommendations set out in the
report and that was seconded and there
was also proposal by Council St that the
report be deferred until burningtown
Council came up with definite Solutions
and that was also seconded so those
motions are to also on the table I just
wanted to make make you aware of that
thank you thank
you Mr quch
well I understand what uh the committee
Clark is saying but when you look at the
minutes which is what counts uh the
minutes say it was resolved that the
meeting was that the matter was
adjourned to the next council meeting as
I understand it so so whatever proposals
were on the table there was a
resolution uh I wasn't there at that
particular meeting so I I can't recall
what happened but that's what the minute
says so we're now we're now in a
situation
where that's been fulfilled we're now
back but the reality was the
resolution was as in the minutes now
that th those minutes are either right
or wrong uh and I don't know but the
minute that's what the minute's
saying yes so I I I think the situation
is that you now have a new proposal
because that with all the other
proposals that were put in whether they
were dealt with rightly or wrongly
obviously I can't say but that's what
the minute says members are happy to
take the councilor Bell's proposal if
you could repeat that councilor Bell for
the benefit of of members and the
committee clerk
please thank you Mr chairman I propose
that we accept option two which is that
meetings remain at Burnham Town Council
thank you thank you very much and that
was seconded by councelor stamp I
believe coun sorry my apologies
councelor White it um so members we need
to put that proposal to the vote Mr
chairman could ask for recorded vote you
certainly can that's seconded by
councilor stamp Tara did you get the
request for a recorded vote please
yes thank you very
much chairman I'm I'm absolutely because
I think this this proposal actually
drifts into the other one which I think
the majority support anyway but chairman
if if pet the monit officer could
confirm um for members that if we were
to uh agree this proposal uh and we did
have issues then under the six Monon
rule it could come back in rather
spookily May which is the first month of
the new Administration so a municipal
year if only I thought of that earlier
and it might have saved a lot of time
thank you Council fluka yes you are
correct it can come back after the sixth
month rule but we'll move to Tara so we
clear that it doesn't work in the next
may it will come
back yeah yeah that's correct okay Tara
thank
you thank you chairman thank you
members so we're voting on The Proposal
from Council if you could indicate for
against orain pleas want to call your
name starting Council please for please
Tara counc B four counc bwood
abstain coun driver
abstain against
thank you coun fto
for
coun for coun Haywood
PA counc
Jennings
abstain coun four please
Tara coun L
four counc leor
four coun Miller
four Morgan
against coun Neil
for counc
PR
four coun
sha
four counc Sid
abstain counc Sid
Norman counc Nicky
abstain counc
Paul abstain
coun
St four coun
Stevens
abstain couns
four counc S
abstain coun
Thompson
against coun white for please Tara and
counc with
four thank you the results are 17 for
four against and seven exensions thank
you thank you very much indeed Tara so
that motion is is successful members we
now move on to agenda item 12 which is
north cess councils which is uh found on
your agenda packs on pages 27 to 50 uh
and I'd ask the leader of the council to
introduce the report please councelor
Sidle uh thank you chair uh so back in
December 2022 22 uh the council uh
agreed the memor memorandum of
understanding we are now moving the uh
North Essex Council group forward in
terms of how it works and the way that
it
works as we've talked about this evening
and we've talked about at previous
Council meetings all councils like
ourselves are in financial difficulties
some are worse than others across Essex
uh and we have to ensure that we work
together
in terms of ensuring that we are
efficient and effective in the future by
working together we can look at how we
share Services the way that we share
services and how we shape together the
north of the district which is what's
crucial in terms of the North Essex
councils one of the things that has been
a debate about recently is about climate
change okay Essex County Council drives
climate change all the north councils
have climate change offices what we need
to be doing is ensuring that we share
that knowledge and we share that
expertise those sorts of opportunities
are ideal where it comes to to the north
essic Council recently we got together
as leaders and chief Executives to work
out what the strategy might be and how
we form that strategy and the issues
that came out of that were things around
housing Economic Development planning
and back office services some
authorities already sharing those
Services we need to ensure that we stay
part of North tics Council so we can
continue to work with them and share
those service and share expertise so we
are as a whole looking for funding to
enable that to
happen because if we were to spend
£2,000 or £40,000 at molden District
Council it would not go very would not
go very far in terms of bringing
expertise as a whole by all contributing
that amount of money we can then produce
something in terms of a plan in terms of
how we work and the way that we work and
ensure we've got the right resource to
work across the the the north of Essex
sitting alongside that is the Northeast
e North North EIC sorry economic board I
would say northeast because of Dean
coming from the Northeast uh and
separately to to to the north etic
Council that's been around a bit longer
than the North etic councils and
therefore has actually produced a lot of
benefits already for the district and
continue to produce a lot of benefits
across the district in in terms of us
working with with uh businesses
interestingly recently we had we had a
presentation which I and uh mp uh Sir
John whittingdale attended on that day
we had 50 business 50 people turn up to
that that uh business meeting the
previous day in brain tree they had four
so that just shows how our businesses
value what we're doing and what how we
should continue funding this what we're
doing in terms of the north essics
economic board is at this point creating
a terms of reference for it and
interestingly I will have a very strong
position in terms of doing that for
molden district because at the last
meeting I was appointed chair of the
board for the next year so I can ensure
that we have a strong voice at that that
particular group and we ensure that when
these things happen the the smaller
rural districts like ourselves and some
others are strongly represented and get
benefit in terms of those things that
are going to happen and those things
that are
implemented that's all I'll say at the
moment that's lovely thank you lader
I'll now pass over to uh Mr Dodson uh
just to introduce the
report thank you chairman um I don't
have a great deal to to add to to what
um the leader has said I think the the
the report sets out that you know the
importance of of North Essex councils
and the the work that's that's being
undertaken there as as the leader has
said particularly around some of those
real big strategic issues around
economic growth housing and and working
collectively with our partners there are
further opportunities as well around
climate action um and it gives us both
the opportunity as a council to to have
a more strategic approach AC with those
Partners but also to have a really loud
strategic voice with Partners including
the the the County Council a potential
um combined Authority and with
government when when we're looking for
for resources so really important work
that that's going um on through the the
north essics councils um and
um the the report clearly sets out the
the recommendations of the resourcing
that's needed to to continue with that
important work thank you thank you very
much Mr Dodson go open the to chamber to
members and councelor stamp you rais
your hand first yeah thank you chair
I've got a few points um recommendation
you didn't read them out so I can uh um
say on this thank you little three it
says for further funding 2425 up to
40,000 will be considered as part of the
2425 budget for the processes blah blah
blah blah blah blah so that actually
means considered but not agreed does it
so if we go for that recommendation it
is agreed so okay so based on that
statement alone what additional benefits
are we going to get for the extra 20K
then the 20K we're already getting so
that's question one please um question
two is on
3.9 and I it says I won't read it
members because you get bored of
listening to me like um I get bored of
listening to myself sometimes it says
can I have more detail how this will
happen and what will the process be in
other words how are you going to deliver
that
statement um also it says 3.12 you've
just actually mentioned and I found
quite fascinating about the brain tree
District board uh that that go to the
accountable body but they only had three
so uh good luck on that one so they
obviously haven't got the support it
says There It Is proposed that brain te
District Council building on the
successful arrangements with the nor
Essex economic board will be the
accountable body for the NEC two separ
things well that's what it says on the
report so answer the question then if
you wouldn't mind expanding and telling
members then what that means because I
obviously don't know what that means so
I've also said uh what will MDC receive
receive for the money 20 grand this year
and last year and the 40 Grand again and
also what are the risks to the council
if we put that money in there thank you
thank you councel stamp C Sid or Mr
Dodson would you care to which one would
like to go first question I'm happy to
Mr doson thank you thank you um taking
them in order the 20 recommendation two
um recommendation two refers to to
20,000 funding that that's been put in
this year what what what recommendation
three is saying that further funding in
2024 25 up to 40,000 will be considered
as part of the
20242 budget process um and that would
be as it sets out for the purposes of
establishing a team to collectively
represent the North Essex councils EST
establish a detailed terms of reference
and a clear program of work and and as
as the leader referred to to develop
that that sort of strategy um through it
and what it refers to in saying will be
considered as part of the 20242 budget
process is that that's been allocated
within the budget process that this
council is going through um for next
year and that's within that that that
funding and that would be agreed through
that process rather than through this
report that's what item three is saying
recommendation thank you
Mr leer I'll sign up to when you can see
me uh yeah in terms of the other thing I
was I was talking about so one of the
things that we're doing is in terms of
the let's do business which is a which
is a neb initiative and it's it's part
of that funding that we've already done
in terms of the north economic board so
let's do business had an event in
Braintree the day before we had an event
in molden and the the event in brain
tree which was held on one of the
industrial States targeted at that
industrial state had four businesses
turned up the day after in terms of
molden dis and this to me signifies how
this important how important it is to
the district and how we support our
businesses and how we ensure that they
get the right funding and get access to
their funding we had 50 people attend
from businesses across the district so
to me that sums up how valuable this
this work is in terms of the north
essics Council it is at an early stage I
can honestly say I I I know you tended
them in the past counselor stamp in the
past there were too much of a talking
shot ex we want to change that and
that's where that F this funding will
come in it is pointless leaders and
chief execs getting together for a
couple of hours just to talk the cost if
you work that out in terms of man hours
is extortionate so to ensure that we are
getting value we have to have this
action plan that is going to be formed
so then we can do those things about
having identify really what we are going
to deliver in terms of the north tic
councils because at the moment that's
not in place the workshop that we did
recently was about forming that action
plan so Within this extra funding we
will be able to have a resource we're
also being funded by esss County Council
in terms of this uh they're very
supportive of the initiative so in terms
of that funding that will ensure
concrete actions for North essics
councils will come forward if it doesn't
me and the other independent leaders are
very you know uh what's the word
constructively and one of the things we
said as independent leaders is this
should not be just a talking shop so
it's by enabling this to happen that it
will that will will change that
situation I hope and I would be theer to
say we should stop this if we're not
getting anything from
it yeah course again Council stand uh
yeah thank you for that so how is that
going to demonstrate to council is it
going to be an interim report every six
months every quarter how often you have
in your meetings because we're actually
asking to spend another 20 grand on top
of the 20 grand and and once I
understand you've got to pay for
resources I have attended the these
meetings and they were talking shops
nothing was achieved for it and at the
moment we're talking about this Council
being cash strapped and I would rather
not lose that 20K if we've got no
assurances that we are going to benefit
and I congratulate your business when at
molden when you had because we saw
pictures online so well done but I would
like to know how many businesses from
where attended that meeting how many was
invited from Burnham southminster I
don't know Bradwell anywhere else
because generally hang on on in my
experience when it's been held at menra
menra at molden it is always molden
Centric or that side of the area and
very rare do we get anything from
Burnham it's not a criticism it's a
question ler thank you uh yeah I'm very
very happy to answer that question and I
can guarantee that there were people
from South menster and Burnham at that
because we talked about and we talked
about a lot of the southminster and burn
and planning issues um during during the
meeting as well so uh and uh Miss cable
will be able to if you want it would be
able to provide everybody who attended
because she had she would have the list
of who the people that that the received
an in or accepted an invitation to that
meeting so that that information can be
provided by Miss cable um if you want so
after after the meeting but I can
guarantee that it really was across
District um there was people from you
know the the the Crouch Valley the you
know from the The Vineyards and there
was also people from the north from
north of the district as well question
of you going to uh so I can't remember
when the next North essics leaders
meeting is but I I am happy to report
that whenever we have a meeting to come
back and report to council along with Mr
Dodson about what we're doing where we
are and the actions that are coming
forward from
it uh councelor Nick spenley please
thank you chair um I broadly support
this proposal I find the 2050 Vision a
bit of a leap of faith uh when I worked
in south end it was a particular leap of
faith given that South End may be
underwater by then even if it hasn't
been blown up by the ammunition ship
which is lying out in the estery but uh
and it's a difficult date to conceive of
particular as I may be residing in one
of our well-kept cemeteries by then but
um I oh thank
you um but I think it makes absolute
sense for authorities to work together
this is not a time to be working in isol
really do need that kind of
collaboration and I welcome the um
reassurance that it won't be a talking
shot thank you very much indeed counc
flu yeah thank you chairman um yeah a
couple of things chairman I mean I mean
the base question is is look we know how
expensive it is to have a seat at a
table I went to IO last week you might
have seen it on Mastermind I won't tell
you how much it cost um but chairman how
was this membership fee arrived at is is
it just the flat membership fee fee or
is it done on the size of the districts
involved because clearly you know we
aren't the same as chumford and we're
not the same as arlesford in fact we are
indeed the smallest uh of the districts
I think in in ess6 and and and I think I
understand what councelor stamp was
alluding to but we're talking about
£20,000 and then we're talking about
£40,000 and just because it's in the
budget doesn't mean to say we can afford
it you know I can put a spaceship in my
personal budget but I can't afford it so
what we need to do and I think this is
what councilor stamp was alluding to was
measuring this and seeing what success
looks like you know if if after a year
or if after 18 months we've invested all
this money and nothing's come back into
the District of any tangible consequence
then we need to know you know because if
we're spending money we don't have we've
got to be absolutely sure that we get
something back from it I'm delighted
that you mentioned South Minster leader
because two of the largest employers in
the in our district are actually in
South Minster and I did pass their names
on to the commercial team and I look
forward to seeing that email of who was
actually there because if they weren't
I'll remind them to go next time thank
you thank you but I think the question
about measuring success German yeah Mr
Dodson do you want to respond to
that yes thank you chair um as the
leader said will report back regularly
um from meetings as as the strategies
developed it will have performance
indicators in and obviously that those
those will be able to to to be shared um
I just wanted to assure that you know
there's already significant um tangible
work coming out of this as well as the
the north essic economic board work that
that has been reported back to the the
council through the the strategy and
resources committee North essics
councils itself will will be holding um
a housing Summit where it's looking at
tangible outcomes of how we collectively
address the housing issues you know it's
been identified through the the work of
the group that housing is one of the the
key strategic challenges not just for
for us as a council um with the um
challenges around temporary
accommodation and increase in waiting
lists but also the the Financial impact
that it's having on a number of councils
and we're seeing um councils raising
risks around section 114 notices because
of the pressure of of Housing and I
think 20,000 or 40,000 is really good
value for money for us if it enables us
to work collectively to avoid those
issues but members are absolutely right
that that we need to report back on that
and demonstrate how progress is being
made um with that f funding thank you
and chairman I think that's a really
good answer but I think you missed the
the question early on uh about how the
membership fee or the contribution was
fixed at thank
you it is a flat
fee oh thank you Mr Dodson um Council
fitok uh thank you chair I mean looking
at the the recommendations the 20,000 is
actually coming from the transformation
fund so that won't impact General
Reserves at all with respect to the
£40,000
it might well be that the directors find
ways to
actually not actually increase that cost
but by using resources that we got but
there has to be a back stop to say if
they can't find the resources within the
organization to do so then we have to be
prepare prepared to fund this moving
forward I mean I I totally agree I mean
if we don't learn and work with other
organizations we're not going to be able
to move forward because we are
constrained with quite a small Authority
but we need the structure that a big
Authority would need so I mean nobody
can know anything so if if I'm sure the
whole purpose of this is that over a
period of time to make us us more
efficient by understanding what other
councils do but more importantly to do
so you need the space to do it you know
you need resources sometimes to think
outside the box and just go away and
look at these matters and not
necessarily constrained by the job that
they're doing on a normal daily basis so
you know I am supportive of that
principle I totally agree we've got to
get it delivered and and show results
but that might take a little while
because often these things are going to
take one two three four years you're
looking at things strategically but I'm
I'm certain that the directors won't be
wanting to do this unless there was
tangible benefit the end of because they
fully understand the pressures the
council's under and it's not going to go
away this year it's going to be every
year is going to be the same pressure so
I'm sure the money will be well spent
thank councelor F councelor White
thank you thank you Mr chairman well I
was sort of in favor of this until I
hear we're playing a fat flat fee and
I'd like to know who agreed that when um
eping Council has a a multi
multi-million turnover and I think they
invested 25 million just to into a
Leisure facility this year and I think
they invested about I think their
planning is 2.75 million they allowed
for that in 2022 to cover their planning
and um if you compare that to our budget
the fact we're all paying the same
amount I'm very concerned um I'd also
like to know uh with the north economic
board um how much funding we received
out of that highways East who told us in
meetings that we were going to be down
the end of the line after all the other
larger authorities who have got a
greater need um how much funding we've
got from that and I'd also like to say
um could we have a break after a year
that if we receive no funding that we
review it and I'd also like officers to
go in and say that we don't accept a
flat fee that it has to be proportionate
I mean a flat fee for these massive
authorities and us that that's like
paying your house insurance that
somebody with a with a mansion that has
to pay insurance of a million pounds a
year and and somebody else who pays a
hundred or ,000 pound a year that we all
agree to pay 50,000 because that's the
flat fee um it just it's a nonsense so
although I agree we should be there I I
my fears are that we'll receive no
funding um and I think there should be a
clause that if we receive no funding
that we can pull out and and the the
other thing is that we review the
funding structure because a flat fee is
not fair it's not fair on our Council
and it's not fair on our residents to
pay the same as eeping and thork and all
these other counties that they must be
laughing that we're all paying the same
amount of money you counc white Mr
Dodson thank you chair if I if I can
start with the the flat fee I think the
the fee is based on the potential poal
benefits that that each of the the
councils receive which is the same
actually it could be argued that it's
greater for for a small Council the
benefit that we'll receive from from
being part of this so it's it's based
not on the the size of the organization
but of the the value that that that's
likely to be received through this this
arrangement in terms of um receiving
funding I think that that statement is
based on a miscon ception um transport
East for example isn't a funding body
transport East is a strategic body um
this would not be a funding body from
which we would receive funding it would
be a body that through which we set
strategic direction we look at how we um
work on shared projects um and there
would be be benefits that are both
tangible through the example I gave
around around housing where we might put
together joint approaches that that
reduce the the risk to the council and
enable us to address some of those needs
around things like um temporary
accommodation through through joint um
purchasing so so there's a there's a lot
of opportunities that aren't directly
about receiving funding and it isn't a
funding body thank you CH Mr dson
Council white just want to come back
quickly yeah if I could come back um
well my concerns with the housing are
thork has received an awful lot of um
people from the London Burrows who can't
afford to house them and I do hope that
we don't agree to fund an awful lot of
homeless people in our district because
we need our district residents to come
first um and I and we keep talking about
the the financial benefits I mean
Highway East is a Lobby a lobbying body
that we pay money into or transport East
and they Lobby for funding but they've
not received we we've not got anything
back for the money we've put into it
from transport East because when I spoke
to them about wooden ferrers they just
said it's you you won't meet the need
criteria because um the a13 the a120 the
main Corridor is what will receive the
funding and you will not be able to make
up a suitable argument to gain funding
um and um so I am concerned about that
and and I do hope officers go back um to
discuss it because if all we're doing is
talking it is just a talking shop um so
let's say I support it but with a few
big caveats and and the the we must see
an outcome and um it must be reviewed
after the outcome and we must review the
flat fee because that's just not
fair thank you councelor white uh
councelor darham please yeah thank you
thank you
uh Mr doson did his best to explain the
fact that this has absolutely nothing to
do with getting f funding nothing
whatsoever nor is it anything to do with
highways and the highways that Council
white has just mentioned are part are
the responsibility of Highways England
that there isn't a single piece of
tarmac in the s in the molden district
that is the responsibility of Highways
England let's just establish the
situation we have 12
districts across the county in Greater
essic obviously not they're not always
in north essic but we've got 12
different ways of collecting the waste
12 planning departments 12 housing
departments all fundamentally doing
things differently the whole point of
this uh North essics council is to bring
the northern councils together and there
is an equivalent body for the southern
councils to look at how we can share
services and do things in a more joined
up
way there is absolutely no doubt we all
know we've spoken about it numerous
times tonight that there is significant
financial pressure not only on molden
but on more or less every single
District um there are some in North
essic that are doing better than others
but that's another matter alog together
so this is an opportunity for us to work
together to potentially share Services
because we can only survive if we reduce
our costs and one of the ways that we
can do that is to share Services by some
of our neighbors in in other authorities
so yes this is uh absolutely essential
that we have a seat at the table that we
are talking to our nearest neighbors and
in fact as far away as atford and um
which is a different matter Al together
and tendering but you know we we cannot
go it alone anymore those days have gone
where little old molden can look to
operate all of its housing its waste
collection planning Etc you know we know
we have a shortage of planning officers
everybody does but surely there is a way
of pooling our resources and we are
stronger together than we are trying to
go it alone thank you and no no
reference to Starships or Elon Musk
either so
um be out of this world um members
before we move over to the
recommendation the vote I'd just like to
say um that thank you for the rep cuz I
thought the report was very succinct and
clear um it's sort of easy to look at
that I'm very much in favor of this
having been a previous Council officer
and I think the the comments that
councelor darham has said are quite
correct that we do need to work together
because it links into my um aspirations
of growth um because as I said I'm not
about the cuts um so much so it gives us
all the opportunity um to have that seat
at the table because we are small but we
have a voice and we deserve to have that
voice there so that's my personal views
on that so members we've had a very
robust debate I'm going to put the
recommendations uh together um if if
that's acceptable to members so uh we
have recommendation one that molden
District Council the council will work
in partnership with those Council set
out in paragraph 3.1 and will
collectively be referred as the north
esset council's Open brackets NEC close
brackets little two that the council
contributes 20,000 from the
transformation Reserve in 2020 3 2024 to
enable resources to be put in place to
manage the work of the partnership and
little three that further funding in
20242 uh of up to £40,000 will be
considered as part of the 2024 2025
budget process for the purposes of
establishing a team to collectively
represent NEC establish a detailed term
of reference for NEC and develop a clear
program of work I so move do I have a
second councelor Paul spenley
second members do we agree by asent no
canc St chairman do you mind if we have
a separate budget line for the two
20,000 then when it comes through so
with 20,000 we agreed and the following
20,000 to be considered when it comes to
this Council so we don't
forget well
it's I think it's CC St I think it's
covering little three I understand that
but it may come as 40 Grand and people
may forget that it was 20 grand and it's
an additional 20 Grand no the maybe I'm
confused it's yeah so this is next
year's budget is 20,000 and then going
forward to
2425 so further funding will be up
to yeah it says that further funding 24
25 up to 40,000 be considered 20 this
year 40 in future yeah 20 this year 40
in future years yeah considered yeah and
that would be that that would be lot
clarified in the
budget okay so I put that recommend
those recommendations to the chamber is
that agreed by asent by any descent
noara that was all agreed thank you very
much indeed thank you
members uh members we move on to agenda
item 13 which is council tax base which
is found on pages 51 to 56 of the agenda
pack uh this report will be presented by
Miss Lucas
please let's have the report first thank
you
thank you chair um so this report um
sets out the um requirement of the
council to agree its tax base for the
financial year
2425 um in order to set its council tax
requirement as part of the budget
setting process the council also has to
notify its tax base to um other
preceptors including Essex County
Council Essex Fire Authority and the
police and crime commissioner for Essex
as well as the parish and town councils
in order that they can also set their
Council taxx um for the next financial
year um so council is asked to approve
the council tax base um for
2425 at
26,400 point2 um as detailed in appendix
one and appendix 2 where it's also
broken down by parish and Town Council
um overall this represents an increase
of um 57.9 Bandy equivalent properties
for the next financial year which
equates to um 1.96% increase on the
current year tax base um I think that's
all I need to say thank you chair no
thank you m Lucas I think that the um
the report and the presentation is quite
clear so I'll just read the
recommendation for the benefit of those
watching at home very many of them um we
have one recommendation that in
accordance with the local authorities
calculation of tax based regulations
2012 the amount calculated by Moren
District Council as its council tax base
for the
20242 year shall be set at
26,400 point2 to have second of the
recommendation great councelor darham
members is that agreed by Ascent AG
thank you members much appreciated uh we
move to agenda item number 14 uh and
this is uh a member vacancy which is
found on pages 57 to 58 uh and this is
to consider the report by the director
of strategy and resources which should
probably be a very small report Mr
Dodson thank you chair yeah very
straightforward report uh councel
Jennings has resigned from the um stry
and resources committee the seat that
was allocated through the statutory
annual meeting um it's a liberal
Democrat seat based on the um political
balance and the liberal Democrat group
has confirmed councelor Nick spenley as
the nomination for the vacany and ask
Council to council to ratify yeah well
basically thank you very much indeed
that speeds things up uh Mr do don't sit
down please um well actually stand up
sit down because the leader's going to
introduce 15 the Six Wide Devolution
update so the leader introduced then
we'll go to Mr Dodson for the verbal
update thank you okay uh thank you chair
uh yeah so the the deily evolution has
moved forward uh we again at the SS
leaders meeting we went through the uh
agreement for the uh combined Authority
uh Mr Johnson and myself were very
strong in putting forward mold's
position and ensuring that we are
represented in the right way and that in
the future we get a good transport
infrastructure obviously education is
part is going to be part of the combined
Authority one of the matters we raised
was that people in the denji can't even
get a bus to go to the colleges so
that's crucial in terms of any
Devolution agreement in terms of
ensuring that molden is is represented
in the right way um obviously we're
still waiting for the decision from
government uh there was a question over
MPS um and you know we got a change in
terms of representation for the north of
the district so uh if the combin
authority goes ahead there will be two
councils uh from the north that will be
have a seat at the table as a support
yeah I can't want the term is Mr but uh
who will be at the table in terms of the
combined Authority without voting
Powers thank you very much indeed Mr
Dodson that update just turned your mic
off sorry didn't you didn't I thank you
Che just just very briefly um twad I
think when I last updated um the chamber
the I said that we were expecting the
deal to be announced within the uh
comprehensive spending review on the
22nd of of November members will have
noted that it wasn't announced within
that and nor was it referred to when a
number of other deals that are in the
pipeline um were referred to whilst the
um the deal and the text has largely
been agreed um in its final draft and
and the governance as as the the the
leader referred to um there is a a hold
up around and I think I think it's
probably correct to say the the deals
currently in limbo due to political
support and that's more at an MP level
than than than local support and I think
those those issues need to to be
resolved for for that to be taken
forward and there was discussion that
the level of about the level of MP
support from all of those MPS covering
greater eics that would be required to
do it and I know there are still
significant discussions going on within
central government to to establish
whether that's the case um my view would
be that if it's likely to go ahead
within the current um Parliament then it
would be probably before Christmas that
a decision would have to be made and and
that would be announced and I know that
on that basis the the um constituent
potential constituent members of that um
combined Authority are looking to go to
consultation should it be announced
Before Christmas they would go to
consultation early in the new year with
enie to to get it in place as soon as
possible um and just finally um chair to
say if members wanted to look at the the
deal it's my understanding that the
Lancashire deal that has been announced
is virtually exactly the same as the one
that's in the pipeline for ess6 thank
you thank you very much de Mr Dodson for
that update um Council fluka very quick
question yeah thanks chairman um yeah
interesting I saw the Lancashire deal
and I I did note that from what I could
research most of their MPS supported it
chairman I I think most people have seen
the comments of Mark fruis MP uh who is
an Essex MP and I I also note that a lot
of our local MPS are silent on this
issue I mean Mark F wi said uh it would
result in more costs to all local
authorities and that it was about the
creation of more jobs in local
government and was something of an ego
trip for some of those involved I
wondered if Mr Dodson and and councelor
Sidle uh concur with those comments and
if not why don't you because they appear
to be the same as those that are coming
from the majority of MPS in
essic than you I don't really think that
um because a model is similar that
that's not the definite model that's
going to be adopted so I don't think I
could actually ask the officers to
respond and the leader to respond at
this moment in time until we have more
details I don't think I've ever seen
such a damning press release from an MP
on the BBC newsread I'm sure you've seen
it all I mean it's extraordinary what
was said bearing in mind what's been
imparted to us in in so far as it's such
a great idea yeah I think that may
members can can take that advice and
that instruction and inform ourselves so
we're a little bit more aware going
forward uh very short this is not a
debate this is just an update so
councelor
darham chairman just chairman I I I
would not be I'm not breaching
confidentiality I'm aware however that
the minister has written to all s MPS uh
and answered their questions um the
there are
apparently three MPS that are now um not
as favorable as they might be Mark
franois is one of them but I don't think
anybody really takes too much attention
of Mark Fran least of all least of all
those people in in his uh in in his
constituency and I know several um and
and uh I have had meetings with Mr
franois and and he is let's just call
him an acquired taste but there are um
no that's fine it's not something it's
it's a view that's widely shared um but
chairman yeah I I I understand that the
on balance the minister is reasonably
satisfied with the level of support that
it now has thank you so um members it
was an update so it wasn't a debate it
doesn't need to be um voted on so I'm
going to move on um because of the
pressing business that we've got after
this um so we've actually moved to
number number 16 which is questions to
the leader of the council in accordance
with procedure Rule 13m and I understand
we do have questions so councelor Pratt
we have a maximum for 15 minutes members
so if you do have questions remember
that there may be other members that
wish to speak the thank you I'll be very
quick will the leaders help me make the
high key more accessible to visiting
yachtsman we I do have an interest
however we have this Council has spent a
fortune on high key it advertises that
visiting yman are welcome the mud is so
high that visiting yachtsman can't get
there so I'd like outside of this
meeting for you and I to actually pursue
it thank you chairman thank you very
much yet I'm more than happy to uh
pursue that with uh councelor Pratt um
obviously with Mr Holmes and and his
team uh can assist on that as well uh
yeah I understand silting is a is a huge
issue at the highest key it's been an
issue for quite a long time um but yeah
if we canut if we can find a solution or
Way Forward then I'm I'm more than happy
to explore that thank you leader um
councelor stamp please thank you chair
I'm a little bit disappointed because I
sent you an email last time if I could
ask the question first and you've given
away to councelor Pratt which I give
away for anyway but well I I did I put
it in writing which is one of the things
we can do um would the leader support an
all member briefing on the burnam on
Crouch pontoon project as within three
weeks it would have been four weeks
before when I had this conversation
before the last meeting was actually uh
um deferred or cancelled uh and
hopefully I had had the conversation
with the director and some of the ground
work may have already been done to
prepare so this briefing could come out
um I'm really concerned about the status
and the position of the replacement P
pontoon and the escalating costs it has
been raised before by some other members
at this Council and I've always been one
to be inclusive of all counselors when
important decisions need to be made so
would you support an all member briefing
leader that everybody gets to know
exactly what's going on and the reasons
for any possible deviations I've go be
careful what I say problems that may
have Arisen thank you
it's one word
yes well I'm going to thank you first
counselor uh I have heard about the
escalating cost I don't know the details
behind it that is it's like all projects
because of the the cost of materials and
things like that the the elements uh how
I am happy to support uh any engagement
with members in terms of being updated
about the Pontoon where that project is
and what the implications are so I'm
happy to support that in any
way indeed can the now can the leader
confirm with the director that that is
going to happen because that was a fudgy
answer it wasn't an accurate
answer Mr
Holmes can we guarantee that that is
going to happen please yes
yes thank you and uh thank you councelor
stamp for registering your
disappointment um has been noted but now
in the constitution does I say I have to
take things in certain orders um one
does One's best but um you know we we do
what we can uh councelor Fluker yeah
thank you chairman I thought i' nodded
off then between councelor Pratt
answering his question Mr holes saying
yes so I look forward to we'll be having
a break in a moment for some coffee look
forward to seeing the PTO dredged um
leader since becoming leader of this
Council you have confirmed and
reconfirmed the importance of members
treating each other with respect and
dignity and the importance of the Nolan
principles at the meeting of the
strategy and resources Committee in
September you made a series of
inappropriate disparaging and personal
comments about some members of the
committee you later apologized which was
considered insincere there is a
precedent that apologies are not
accepted by members of the council that
said do you agree with me that you're a
Hipp hypocrite and can you explain to
council and residents why you won't do
the right thing by your own words to
this Council on several occasions and
resign at the September meeting I made
no personal comments about any
counselor what I did say was I made
referral to a a political party at that
that uh
meeting at no point have have I had an
issue in terms of my own behavior during
my four and a half years of being a
counselor I have always abided by the
Nolan
principle at that meeting I did put a
apology to the meeting and the chairman
of the meeting accepted my apology the
fact that the chairman accepts my
apology I assume means it is the right
thing to
do yeah if at any time
anybody thinks that I have behaved
inappropriately I would welcome a
conversation with
them um and that's all I can say thank
you very much indeed uh councelor
Jennings please uh thank you um I just
wondered when
a picture of the king will be appearing
in the
chamber it's to the leader but allow the
chairman to ask you can yeah we yes um
her the light Her Majesty the protocol
is normally when the new portrait of the
king is taken with the king and queen uh
the previous Monarch picture is then
removed um officers have been working on
this uh and made a request for myself to
to actually take a picture of her
Majesty down and place it into the
members room while we await the new
portrait uh I think it's early January
when his majesty has his picture taken
um so that is when that the change will
happen so it has been raised and it's a
very important
point Thank You councilor white coun
I'll be very quick thank you chairman
for allowing me to speak uh my question
really follows on from councelor Pratt
and I would like to ask the leader
whether it would be possible for other
interested members to form a a small
group for the siltation um because I
personally work very closely and done a
lot of work with Dr Charles bule from
the environment agency and I Al work
also work very closely with natural
England and we have created one of the
best um uh Brent geese sites um in Essex
um and it's not a public site um so I
have a lot of knowledge on this it is
important so I wonder if the leader
would agree with me that it would be
useful to include other informed members
Within a siltation group or a river
Blackwater group because it is really
important and I know that they say the
antifouling and the M mollusks are a bit
of a problem but we there has to be a
balance somewhere and I think if we have
the will we can achieve it because we
need to support the barges we need to
support boat users and we need to
support molden and the district is what
we're famous for thank
you thank you Council white uh one of
the things we are looking at in terms of
the Committees and working groups is we
have far too many working groups and the
last thing I want to do is create
another working group uh I would assume
that the heke comes under our assets so
therefore if there is something around
assets the river that would be the
appropriate working group for that
discussion to take place in so if that
is something that would need to go to
that particular working group I'm sure
that working group would would be happy
to to to welcome that and also you know
for anybody who's interested if they're
not a member of the working group to
participate and get
involved thank you leader councelor Bell
may I come back
no y certainly can thank you uh for that
leader um but I don't as you'll be well
aware I don't sit on any working groups
at all um there is a family interest I
don't own any of the foreshore however
family members do um and I think that
with the knowledge that I have working
with groups even if you don't want any
more working groups even though I don't
sit on one perhaps this could be a
specific member LED
exercise thank
you if if if members want to form their
own group and do their own thing there's
nothing to stop that uh what what we
need to do is ensure that any action by
the council goes through the relevant
working group The High key is an asset
so therefore anything like that should
be through that that the asset working
group black water isn't an asset it's
not own by the crown not the district so
if therefore it's if it's a crown it
should that needs to be taken to the
crown and not to ourselves uh you know
in terms of saltation in terms of those
things yeah my view is it is it would be
appropriate to go to the asset working I
don't whether Mr Holmes can advise
me thank you very much indeed um
chairman sorry yes certainly can um
uniquely we do own the river Black Water
you don't you don't own all that we own
up to the um high water mark which is
fairly unique in in our district and
obviously siltation is a Riverwide issue
doesn't respect that boundary so just
just wanted to make the point that we we
are in that unique
position thank you very much counc fluca
thank you chairman um just because of my
earlier motion it doesn't mean he said I
don't want to work with the leader and I
did actually send him an email just then
to try and help him out oh right okay
right leader if leader do you agree with
me that this Council has a facilitation
working group group or is involved with
the siltation working group uh which
looks at siltation and that we also have
a member the same member sits on the mod
Harbor Improvement Commissioners and do
you agree with me leader that if anybody
has any issues with this as that member
they should contact me and if anybody
has any specific ones leader they're
welcome to join me next time we go down
the river to look at all the issues with
siltation
yes ex counc dar
yeah I'm going to have to frame this as
a question so would the leader agree
with me that actually there is an
award-winning uh area in the district
that is Nory iseland and the chairman
will remember that it won a
sustainability award um it's owned by6
Wildlife trust and it is recreating very
large areas of salt marsh for the birds
including Brent geese um and it is uh
absolutely a um an exemplary model of
how to work with with the salt marsh and
the uh and our Coastline thank you thank
you very much
indeed yes councelor G as as someone who
when I was very very young was an
environmentalist and did lots of study
on the salt marsh uh and the fact that
we have the river black water and the
river crash which are areas of special
scientific interest you unique to the
country uh especially at this time of
year when the winter birds come in so
anything in terms of that yeah we have
to we we should be proud of in terms of
yeah what our district stands for and
what's in our district thank you leader
uh we've got councelor spenley please
councel Paul
spenley thank you chair leader I have
asked this question before but I'm going
to bring It Forward again so some of you
here some members including yourself
will remember when I um came to for
Council and asked for the North
haybridge Flood alleviation scheme
reference group to be set up that group
has still not been set up so I realize
and I I know that Mr Dodson is will have
updates and understand but we've got new
members and even if it's to update them
on where we are so
far um I'd just be really grateful to
have that because it has come to my
attention and I don't want to speak
about this too much in here that if the
scheme is to go ahead it will need
agreement by February
2025 and if we haven't even had a
briefing for the members involved as yet
I think we're letting it drift on so I
just would be really grateful bearing in
mind very quickly that you know it is so
important to us locally myself and
counselor B bwood have residents were
deeply concerned about who because of
the failure of the first scheme are
paying these huge CH flood alleviation
charges for for residents
elsewhere and my feeling on that is the
new scheme may or may not help resolve
that for them and when I spoke to the
environment agency at the ess6 flood
World they thought that it might but we
just need an update of some sort so
please can I ask for that to happen
thank you thank you thank
you it is extremely important and it is
one of the most contentious issues in in
you in the the molden area especially um
and I would you I would welcome the
opportunity to be able to give
especially Ward members an update around
that that particular area um how that's
done and the way that it's done whether
that's done through the the local the
Planning Group or whether it's done as a
separate briefing I don't know but I'm
sure that we can find a solution in
terms of ensuring that members are
updated about where that particular
project is and and making sure that we
are we all know about it thank you um
member uh leader I have a question um
would you uh agree with me that it would
be Sound Logic that on the hi key that
discussions can be undertaken with the
river uses either barge Community bars
trusts uh and other vessels that lay
alongside there who may be able to work
with us to offer a solution to remove
some of the mud um in with regard to
some possible slight reduction in cost
um a neutral cost of the cost it takes
to remove the Mad to in in in in in
conjunction with a a reduction in their
more in fees if they were if that was of
that body um and that that to be taken
to the director of Service delivery to
be considered um as a
program bit splattery but you know what
I mean to think uh I I think that yeah
that could be an excellent idea uh and
the whole thing about the sortation is
the is the cost of of doing it and if we
can share that with with other River
users with barge owners whoever it is
yeah and look at a solution whether that
then involves a discount I can't say
that that would probably have to be
agreed by Council um but again being
collaborative in terms of what we're
trying to do as a dish in terms of what
we're trying to do at Council the more
collaborative we are the better the
solutions are so I think we should
collaborate as much as we can thank you
Lisa I can take that to the um director
of Service delivery as as a
collaboration document to consider to
come to council yeah thank you leader um
we've actually finished with 49 seconds
so thank you we we've used that time
very productively um members thank you
for your questions we move on to item 17
which is business by a reason of special
circumstance that considered by the
chairperson to be urgent I have none uh
we KN now move on to item 18 which
exclusion of the public and press and
this is to resolve the under Section 104
of the local government act 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting for
the following item of business on the
grounds that involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph three of part one
of schedule 12a of the act and that
satisfies the public interest test I so
move members agreed thank you members
Atara could you end the live stream
please